you
hi everyone it's Jerry I'm on leeches
org and I just got paired up playing a
15-2 game against mg CH first time
playing against this opponent a d4 d5
game already a Slav yes okay what to do
against this love we could go boring or
not boring
already
now what okay let's go for g3 Bishop g2
not usually my preference to allow the
capture on c4 and try and show
compensation for being down upon but
let's give it a go see what we can learn
from this okay well they're not going in
for that
hmm all right well they could still
capture I'm holding off on Knight to c3
because I may do something like this hmm
I may be tempted to play Knight to d2
right now yeah why not I mean they black
has not declared like has not brought
out their LightSquared Bishop outside
the pawn chain so I could avoid all this
stuff where
you know maybe my opponent grabs the
pond and tries to hang on to it by
playing Knight to d2 right now
oh it isn't it gets in the way of my
dark square bishop but I don't really
think I know where my dark square bishop
belongs for a while let's go with this
so I'm just prepared to recapture on c4
simple enough we really like to see this
these two moves have been invested in
order to reinforce d5 one of the ideas
at least and to give it up I think would
be to concede something all right where
else is he gonna go let's hold off
though pink huh
it's hang on for a second am I missing
anything careful careful careful
all right Bishop g2 he knows his place
whoa interesting b5
hmm I haven't seen that one before
what to do when you're caught off guard
I'm used to it I'm used to it don't try
to catch me off guard in an opening
because I'm always caught off guard
I'm used to it all right so what to do
in reply to b5 I don't want to take I'd
still like to keep the tension I don't
want to give up my c4 pawn for their c6
pawn that's basically what happens as
soon as I capture is there any drawback
connected with b3 can I work that one
out I don't think so hmm I mean with
this stuff start to be a bother I don't
think so
okay I'm gonna go speed three
and and this is the other way I should
have looked at it I'm preparing to
develop my dark square Bishop a
multi-purpose remove I love it nihilist
recapture
okay now the B file is completely opened
not so sure I want to step foot on the V
file with my bishop
where is there a difference in this
position okay very direct play from Team
Black Sea five you have no fear of this
do you no fear
fearless opponent okay well I have to be
careful about inviting this Knight into
my position or inviting this Knight into
a position where he eyes up one of the
squares in my position namely c3 c3 as a
whole so chop-chop 9c3 maybe I should
still do that though okay well well I
can I try to make something work here I
mean this is an unprotected rook he's
opposite my bishop just a couple of
pieces in the way but I'm not afraid of
this capture because of this so let's
let's keep this tension
at the same time is there an idea
connected with takes takes e5 no I don't
think so I think I should hold ground
here and simply castle yep let's castle
and let's see where he goes
as mentioned I don't want to play to be
too so quick at least and I imagine
black would be hesitant to put their
Bishop on b7 because of this this was
maybe an idea as well instead of castles
maybe the Queen comes out here but you
know similar situation we have we have
similar moves here
Knight b3 Knight b6 and reply to Queen
moves boom boom
and boom-boom
at some point at least
all right I don't know if I'll make a
habit of going forward those sound
effects sound effects are just the names
of us honed anyhow then Bishop d6 it is
hmm
so this makes me think about capturing
and on night takes I have night c4 or a4
with the valuable tempo so if I capture
here okay so I I'm pretty sure that I
could saddle white with an isolated pawn
or be able to move my knight forward
with tempo I get one of those two things
I think or I'm tending towards one of
those two things by initiating this
capture C takes D I think I want to do
that
he is unprotected let's strike you know
what here's another let's let's smash
open the position let's let's make some
captures here black still is one move
away from castling black still has a
king that's on an open diagonal so maybe
I could somehow put this to use maybe I
could somehow put to use that this rook
is unprotected opposite my bishop now I
could go in for this move here here and
this is what I mean I'm just one capture
away and then I could try to play
against this guy however do I have a way
to maybe take advantage of this bishop
that's unprotected or Queen a
if castles queen c6 would that be
winning some material hitting the bishop
and the rook I think in that situation
castles queen c6 there is a move Queen
b6 defending the bishop and if I take
the rook Bishop here
if I play Bishop III there's queen a5 I
don't want to allow C form so maybe I
could have started with that and I could
have shared that thought first so I
don't want to allow a connected passed
pawn so this move I'm ruling out c4 with
tempo and yeah no thanks
it seems like a really simple way to
play it just capturing and following up
with Knight to b3
instead of this ideally I want a dark
square Bishop exchange and then drop a
night in to d4 blockade that isolated
pawn so I guess we're gonna give that a
go I mean what's keeping me from this is
Queen a 5h mmm any other tricky stuff
available I mean this kind of stuff I
want to be able to move by night soon
let's do this this is also a new square
for my f3 night don't know that I could
really take advantage of this rook
that's on a a but it's opened up some
night here right now
hmm or should I know could I do this
right now
no probably not okay I don't think I
have a better square for my night let's
get him into b3 I want some exchanges
it's my phone has an isolated pawn but
there are still playing with the full
set of minor pieces four to four welcome
to exchanges in these position types in
this structure type opponent has an
isolated pawn ideally the square that's
directly in front of that pawn well what
color is it it's dark okay that's a good
move avoid in exchange dying of c3 I was
going to say the block hating square is
d4 dark square I want a dark square
bishop exchange so that I can jump here
and stay there more reliably okay c3 is
sensitive I referenced this some time
ago it's a hole in my position so I
think now this should be too is fine I
didn't want to do this a little bit
earlier when there were still B and C
ponds around but he's got to get him
this dog and I'll know and now what to
do
probably rook to c1 I got it I gotta go
a little bit faster let's kick it up
some
let's see where this Bishop goes if he's
no longer around here and this starts to
be appealing combined with my bishop on
b2 there could be a an attack right
around the corner some you start to see
some coordinated pressure against the
heart of blacks King side g7
Bishop a6 interesting well can I not
just follow through what with what I
said
ain't here to here I could also do this
what
better I feel on this move the Queen's
gonna play here I think I want to keep
my knight around watching over 85 hmm
all right let's try this my opponent's
playing fast and good moves
that's uh that's trouble flowing fast
and making good moves
so I'm eyeing up f5 c6
it's the Queen but what more
this is a real tough guy right here on
e4 it's on my side of the board I don't
like that this is also holes well
pointed out c3 but c4 should really be
capturing my attention hmm yeah Bishop
c4 that's probably where the bishop is
headed my knight in time you know could
be his position can be challenged with
that a pawn
they have to find a new square happy to
see that my opponents thinking this is
possibly a move
I normally would not want to move my
f-pawn but maybe I have to do this I
have to maybe give something up in order
to get something to gain some control
over this square so actually I mean if I
go here where's this night headed he
only has one square
I feel like I should try that oh you
know what another thing is with the
Queen here defending at five if I kick
the night away he goes to g5 I could
drop in here and get the bishop hair
I think this is worth it I don't think
they'd give up the dark square bishop
but even so I'd get I get the light
square bishop and they could try to put
this guy to use somehow it is extra
weakening when I do put if I do push
with f3 but I take over control of a
square
I convenience that night some don't I I
really jump in here
what more
another candidate move besides f3 I
think this is a way forward let's give
it a shot
tough position
tough position so
9 h3 king h1 should I play age that's
getting really weakening huh well I
could pull the Queen away from that I
think Knight c5 is the way how good is
this night on b3 I mean really how good
is he hmm and I'm fearful of this here
and then Bishop c4 somehow am i rook
getting stranded
a little bit scary maybe no no no I
don't want to do that let let's go with
Knight to c5 I know I'm don't have a
great train of thought going in this
game but it's a it's sharp open position
a lot of a lot of possibilities here
that'll save me a bunch of time making
uh getting a pre move ready yeah okay
he's gone now my ponies without a dark
square bishop can my dark square Bishop
be a pain somehow I want the Queen's off
can I somehow make that happen Queen d2
hits with tempo that's nice
I could take the night I mean if he goes
here my F on controls this night I like
that I have a good night I have a loose
piece here on B - maybe I should be
scanning this position for that kind of
stuff
a couple unprotected pieces yeah Bishop
c4 thought you might do that
oh my bishop here I wouldn't mind seeing
this trade Queen d2 going to d2
yeah let's go Queen d2 also my rook
could maybe be rescued if he's uh you
know attacks from how with the Knights
he has another square he's going there
okay so probably just exchanged in the
nights
okay I'm really close to coordinating my
pieces really well Bishop here I think
you have to take with the pawn you know
they go with the pawn
bishop here
pairing to enter
defend the a to pun with that mouth
clean a 4 seems pretty strong hmm all
right let's post up here for starters I
don't know how I'm defending my a to
pawn if Queen a4 yeah Queen a4 strong
because then there's even 9700 oh
actually Queen a4 I have rook a4 mm-hmm
shake you my rook around after this he's
a bit stranded let's not do that it
probably just exchange rooks here
my queen has a responsibility to babysit
these two pawns she's not happy about
that
what about Bishop here applying pressure
to this pawn I like that yeah let's do
that actually it stops Knight d7 as well
if I can draw the arrow right boom
take that e6 pawn
however oh it's queen a6a move
my rook active bishops on adjacent
diagonals here the three minutes four
seconds I got the bishop here I have a
strong bishop here
clean they're now preparing Knight to d7
is that what you have up your sleeve
maybe
Queen here I give up my epon and I don't
like that
huh
go a3 and then clean here I need to save
my a pond I believe
yeah let's just move them oh there's a
check
I'm sorry I thought
this queen has a responsibility
clean they're tough tough tough tough
tough tough
okay I guess here
putting a lot of pressure on me
I believe on Knight d7 I have to do this
just dreamed about my dark square bishop
oh why would I think that though no not
necessarily I could I can drop my bishop
back there still yeah are these my King
is on this diagonal it's not fun having
to babysit this pawn I'd like two queens
off how much of a bother with this movie
you know can I just play here control
this diagonal
well control the night I mean
can take the night out an e5 push move
like this threatens mate in one
pressure here defense there pieces
flying around everywhere I could do
something like F 4 maybe even push here
c4 what good is my e2 pun I mean why not
get him contributing I mean I know I I'm
a little bit more vulnerable on the
second rank but
they will have to be concerned about the
f3 pawn as well
maybe I could get my pawn up to a five I
think I could rely upon my queen on D to
my final be defended here no Knight b6 I
know this can't be so yeah
wait isn't so comfortable with that what
about
hmm huh then it's going to say king f2
here
about f4 just stopping e5 altogether not
Queen g5 my threatening Queen d8 I could
just do something more solid here how
about I put more pressure
yeah I'm defending the upon I'm more
pressure here I like this move maybe
even grab no not giving an inch not even
an inch man I think I want my king upon
f2
help defend e2
get my H phone working somehow break
down the dark squares far-fetched maybe
okay I think I have good coordination
and the important pawns cover these are
the tool um sensitive pawns they have a
couple sensitive pawns as well
interesting position I prefer my queen
position
a bit more central
I have some nice dark square control
let me just try to get some quick moves
in here I mean I I have to go with some
quick moves
my opponent has already shown with a
couple a couple cases in the game felt
like they were able to rip off some
moves fast
what to do I have these squares that
have to be careful about where they go
with the dark squares I think I've
managed to work around this light square
bishop well
there's something more direct than
Bishop here h4 h5
holding off on this I don't want a week
in e4 this pawn is pinned so he is not
controlling these two squares for as
long as this rook is here I want to make
sure I can keep my bishop here I have
everything protected in this position
the it's a dark square Bishop versus
Knight type position I have him exactly
where I would want that dark square
Bishop on the main diagonal
cannot be so comfortable having a night
on f8 I could get my rook doing
something else I don't need my rook on e
one instead of this I should be looking
to activate my rook
so Brooke to be one my last move is
freeing up my rook whoa really
how can you do that did not think that
that was possible
giving up a paan could take with the
queen of the bishop if I take with the
Queen I drop my a paan
that that's okay I wanna keep my Bishop
there but what's wrong with Bishop takes
pawn
let's just take you have to show me
they're gonna put me in a pin
have f/4
you
you can also play Queen here to get out
of the pin and then back up
well if the follow-up is not rook to e7
I'm not sure what is otherwise why why
would black it's the only way to kind of
mmm keep me off balance you know have me
work out of some stuff what's that move
about
okay trying for that move but let's go
here
am I missing less than 30 clean here
have this
now nope in others still no there isn't
night there okay let's get here next
Bishop g4 I have I'm up upon maybe
winning one
let's get that clean out of there
h4
their Bishop is out of play and
to be one hmm let's try this probably
play h5
but that gives up Queen g5 Queen g5 is a
move
I think I want making back over here Wow
hmm
going fast
rook is ready to enter
my bishop could defend that a pond if
the Queen's are off I don't think
there's any issue with Bishop c5
Queen goes too far I could pick this guy
up
okay
pressure there as well okay
so let's start with this defend that
pond
probably has to challenge my yeah okay
let's just answer
check I think this is good for time
banking reasons and also this follow-up
in which this must now be winning
rook here to here should be a
game-winner let's glue my bishop in how
do they get out of this pin the bishop
is out of play these squares are covered
can't go here this is a serious threat I
think it's just a winning idea now
so let's do it No
Bishop takes pawn is there think I have
to do this first I could have also just
defended that now okay right here this
is working pawn push I could take with
my rook the knight is pinned rook takes
pawn Bishop takes Knight is the threat
here now I'm getting the night
and they're going to get that epon
petrel here is there
okay just challenged that rook
I may have just plundered my rook bishop
f1 now
man
I'm just letting that pond March all the
way down this is really bad
oh they're doing that
huh I thought they could have just
pushed that pond I did not play this uh
well this ending part also I should be
giving a check
pick up that pond okay now I have
control now that he's gone scary there
for a second I thought there was like
some bishop f1 rookie to idea let's get
back here let's blockade that pond and
they resign move tough tough tough man
a lot of resistance there to go through
the analysis hmm yeah definitely had to
watch over those base points and I think
I covered them well it was felt like
very direct play early on like going
without b5 and then capture captures c5
Wow
okay well what to say a slob a modern is
what it says
going with g3
yeah v5 move interesting
chop-chop c5 doesn't get too much more
direct than that
position opened up very fast I got to
share a lot of what I wanted to during
the game just saddling black with an
isolated pond and trying to play against
it but opponent was a very stubborn not
too quick to just trade pieces 94 is a
good move Bishop they're like c1 you
know this was this was scaring me
bishop on c4 what's the evaluation sing
it's not quite finished still a lot to
chew on such an open position now f3
right f3 yeah I get the bishop and then
I'm able to coordinate
I don't I'm not a I'm not dropping my a
pond I wonder about this decision night
here mm-hmm it's even saying that f
takes is a blunder oh I have a
game-winning continuation here
chop-chop game over this doesn't even
reach move 25 haha hi mr. tactical
sequence
so on 96 Queen has to capture
mmm didn't even what was I so focused on
I was positional features improving a
bishop not a bad move of but of course
this is just a flat-out win by taking
the knight I'm removing the defender of
the Queen and then I could take
advantage of this pin on the D file but
it was it was still an interesting game
right got to see some interesting stuff
even though I had a game-winning
continuation there as it finished yeah
there you have it both of us with our
share of mistakes and blunders you know
okay so a missed opportunity here to end
the game and let's just what the
analysis on
and see what more was missed now I could
even pin the night
um when you have the bishop pair I think
having another having a knight exchange
is desirable because it's one less night
you have to worry about one day
attacking one of your bishops so there's
happy to see this exchange but yeah I
didn't follow up with the game-winner
Bishop takes Knight can always say I
mouse lift that right
not quite Bishop e5 xe8
yeah I guess I held on to the advantage
throughout confirmed by the graph yep
I thought towards the end though there
was some kind of draw but now I guess
there never really was a drop it was a
little bit scary when I'm playing that
rook a trip to H to move and there's
these Bishop f1 moves I'll have a look
at that
control over these dark squares I'm not
sure what he five was about
I figured you know this you have to try
to pin that's what it's suggesting and I
think I was pointing out I could play
queen here
well it also wants to get the rook
activated right away if this night comes
here I have rip to b8 oh that's an
interesting move
I take take take and then I dropped the
bishop but I guess I could do without
that rook to b8 sharp open position
bishop air
okay
Queen g8 back up
yeah and I'm consolidating here I'm
better here I could do without Bishop to
g4 so right around this point I was
saying when was it oh right around here
I was of the mentality okay
Yeah right around here I was
the mentality okay here here but I
should really be looking to get my rook
active this last move frees up my rook
so before I go with these exaggerated
type of plans first things first we cut
an open file maybe even rook down here
to pin the knight and if I want to go in
for this low improving type of moves
later do that but this should come first
this should this should have been
registering in my thought process much
much sooner rook to be one when I wanted
to play rook to be one was right around
here but Queens now guarding that
and then get rolling with the H pond
they're active Queen g5 Queens are gone
and I should be pushing defend is fine
and now this is a good idea to give a
check wants to go in the corner but I
guess even if in the corner there's an
issue with this
mating ideas actually making to stuff
yeah so as soon as the night move this
is this is long gone now because of the
check really I was just doing it to bang
some time and I knew that the king would
have to drift towards the edge not the
center so something's gained from that
and after this Bishop f5 is a killer but
I did not convert this as as clean as I
should have likes likes King left ooh
Oh III I could do this but this scared
me a little bit Chuck here no I gotta do
this kind of stuff I want to cleaner way
where I'm coordinated along the way so
look there now I could take and I could
take like I did in the game kingi one
and right here there's no way I should
have allowed this pond to get as far as
he did my rook is a little bit offsides
I just want to get him over here down
here really for me
rook h2 and this is where I thought
there might be some kind of Perpetual
like a bishop check King here oh and on
a rook Chuck I don't have to take the
bishop like I play here
okay I wasn't just I wasn't seeing those
moves towards the end there with seconds
on my clock but Brooke h2 is fine in the
end there isn't some fancy for petrol or
light it doesn't have to give up the
bishop for rook give up the rook for the
bishop or anything like that so I guess
it was alright how I played it but yeah
it was a little bit scary yeah I
shouldn't it can't this pawn just push o
on push probably have rook b2
I was I was eyeing that move up in the
game if the pond push because I knew I
would have a check and then the bishop
could take the queen but it's more than
check its leading to me so that's the
idea but this was a scary pond in game
yeah it was definitely scary
and after the rook trade it's simple my
bishop controls both of these guys and I
could slowly improve
okay well interesting game clearly a
missed tactic right there in the middle
game with couple capture sequences here
chop-chop but uh yeah I was still
interesting I thought very tense both of
us having to watch over some base points
here right here ecigs and a7 for black a
3 and E 2 for me tough struggle
okay well as usual feel free to leave
any feedback to this video in the
comment section below and I will catch
you in the next one that's all for now
take care bye
you